The cult of the productivity hack begins, as all great miseries do.
With a stopwatch and a clipboard, though, these days, the tools are shinier.
In the 1920s, Frederick Taylor's efficiency experts marched into factories like surgeons with a mission,
dissect every motion, time every blink, and turn labor into something so precise it forgot its own purpose.
The workers didn't just lose their hands to the rhythm of the assembly line.
They lost their minds to the how of it all.
And now? Now we've virtualized the whole affair.
We call it the cult of the productivity hack.
Here's the secret.
To be truly miserable, you must never do work.
You must only engineer it.
Spend your days designing systems, optimizing workflows,
building loops of activity that hum with the quiet satisfaction of motion without meaning.
Become a maven not of results, but of process.
Track your steps while walking nowhere.
Audit your desk while staring at the wall.
The more you refine the machinery of your own stagnation, the more you earn the sacred title, Busy.
And oh, how the planning fallacy loves you.
Psychologists have a name for it.
The way we underestimate time,
overestimate control, and turn every project into an endless prologue.
The maven weaponizes this flaw.
Four hours spent setting up a second brain for a two-hour task?
Perfect. You've just perfected the art of avoidance.
All while collecting the miserable credit of being productive.
The Zygarnik Lubar brain's stubborn hold on unfinished tasks becomes your greatest ally.
Transfer those tasks to a new app the moment you master the old one.
Feel fresh.
Feel premium.
Never actually finish.
Then there's the theater of deep work.
Two hours preparing your environment, adjusting the lighting, curating the binaural beats,
performing a system audit of your desk, until suddenly you're ready.
And by ready, we mean exhausted.
The kitchen of your mind, once a place of creation, is now a graveyard of half-started rituals.
You've optimized your own paralysis.
Or perhaps you'll try habit stacking.
Ten new habits at once.
Decision fatigue sets in.
The system collapses.
And instead of admitting failure, you call it systemic.
Because, in the cult of the productivity hack,
personal responsibility is a relic of the unoptimized past.
You're not lazy.
You're refening.
And then, there's the dashboard.
Track your sleep, your mood, your caffeine, your steps.
Anything to turn living into data, breathing into metrics.
The ultimate numerical obsession, monitoring your life instead of living it.
You're no longer a person, you're a manager of the void.
The goal?
To become the most organized, cross-referenced failure in history.
Worth ten hours a day.
Produce nothing.
Optimize your own obsolescence.
You're a masterpiece of modern efficiency, a human assembly line.
Turning air into effort, motion into meaninglessness.
Consider the morning routine from hell.
Meditation.
Journaling.
Cold plunge.
Supplement stacking.
By the time you're done, it's 11 a.m.
And your emotional reserves are as depleted as a factory worker's spirit in 1920.
You can't even answer an email.
But that's the point.
A sharp axe is useless if you spend all day sharpening it.
Keep the stone spinning.
And the stone, it's always spinning.
Talking for you.
Here's the hidden succulent.